Why don't we talk to oh, we have a Philip. I
can't see the name, but we have a Filipino caller.
Filipino caller. What's your
name? It's just not showing up.
So I am Jentleson and beyond from the
Philippines, sir, did you say John Christian?
Yes, sir. How are you?
Fine, sir. Well, I have to
say here that America that America you voted for
by the right was in the Philippines is kind of
a shambolic democracy because our president,
Rodrigo Gallego, at the FAA decided to shut down
at the end. He led by political activists who
accused the vice president, many of Robledo, of
showing off in a typhoon. And now they are not
bringing on this. The Department of Education,
they found our secretary said that face to
face classes. What happened was you expect
a savvy divorce is similar to my secretary was
a on it. So I have to ask you, the question is,
if President Bush says that ends this thing,
he will go to the International Criminal Court
because the ICC said that there is enough evidence
to say that he has committed crimes against
humanity for murder, for extortion, for
political stealing and everything from his
term in office.
I'm still in my mouth.
I think that it is almost without question
that Rodrigo Duterte has committed
horrible crimes and and yet I don't think it's
particularly likely he will be brought up on
charges in front of the International Criminal
Court. I don't see it as likely, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, well, I think the president of the
Philippines and his supporters are as horrible as
Trump supporters, because I think you're right,
they realize everything, everything they fall
into, including of being a one by no one,
is talking about the Liberal Party, which is
the party, but for the party. So. Right. My follow
up question is, if Joe Biden and Kamala Harris did
the unthinkable in 2020, what advice would you
say to Filipinos like me who will vote in the 2024
Philippine presidential election? Because this
is not about the fact that this is the future of
the country in the next two years. And we have
seen here that looked at this and I can she lie
still and manipulate, just like
Mr. Marshall did in the 1980s.
Right. Well, listen, I wish I had specific advice,
but without being as familiar as you are with the
specifics of how he will attempt to remain in
power, it's hard for me to say anything more
than generally we need everybody to vote that
that was the mean here and enough people did
that. We have we have removed Trump. Now, you're
shot out of a cannon today. You're completely
on fire. And I have to ask, are you speaking
into a phone but talking through a megaphone?
No, I know I'm not speaking through a
megaphone. I am here to tell the truth. OK. This
is a murderer. Yes, I did say I read a human
rights denier. And there is no question that the
ICC has rules that that they should be charged.
I think you're right.
I think you're right. I think you're absolutely
right. And we are going to listen very closely
and see if we can figure out how you
achieved such a unique vocal sound.
It sounds almost like there's a bandsaw going
in the background, but I'm going to let you go.
I really appreciate the call and a wow, that is
a high energy call. And I sympathize politically
with the situation in the Philippines. There's
no doubt about that. It's it is something else.